extra police officers are on patrol this
morning here in New York City in the
wake of those attacks in Spain CBS News
national security analyst Fran Townsend
was homeland security and
counterterrorism advisor to President
George W Bush Fran good morning first
with the news US law enforcement
officials telling CBS News this morning
that they have indications this was more
than just an inspired isis attack what
does that mean
well if you look at the events as they
unfolded right you had the house which
blew up when they failed to put together
these gas canisters probably for a car
bomb then you had the tragic sort of 7
block right rage of this car killing 14
you also had out in Canberra last night
the another car attack people injured
you've got five dead there they were
wearing suicide belts so you can see as
you look at the chronology this was a
fairly large cell had to have been in
place for a while pretty good planning
although their execution right of the
explosive elements was not so good and
so I think that this looks like as
you're hearing from law enforcement now
more much more directly controlled than
just merely inspired this wasn't
somebody who got up and decided to take
a car and Ram it in a crowd this was
much more deliberate them and is that
the way it's going to go down these days
now Fran there's you just get in a car a
vehicle and just mow people down there's
a story in The Washington Post this
morning that people in the area were
upset that there weren't barricades in
place to prevent this well I think we've
seen you know whether it's in Great
Britain or France more and more areas
that are restricted you know there are
no vehicles where there are pedestrians
on yeah we're correct and so I think
you're gonna see more and more of this
because it's difficult once somebody
gets the car and decides to use it as a
weapon it's almost impossible to prevent
them unless you have these vehicle
bearing this was a reasonably large cell
this could easily have been much worse
that's right if these guys had
successfully executed on the explosives
right you can imagine instead of just I
I don't want to minimize it using the
car as the weapon imagine if the car had
exploded you know in a large public area
they didn't have automatic weapons the
this terror cell seems to be similar in
size to the one in France two years ago
the guys and France had automatic
weapons
guys did not why well you know it's
interesting we need to know more about
who the individuals are that have been
killed and are at large I expect that it
the cell will be comprised not only of
Spaniards but probably of Moroccans
coming from North Africa and to come
that sort of flow of extremists you've
got across a body of water it is more
difficult and typically the Spanish
between 2013 and 2016 have arrested a
hundred and seventy-eight extremists 40%
of them have been Moroccans forty
Spaniards
you know they're going to want to
understand the composition of this cell
their travel patterns communications and
how they were able to coordinate and get
the component parts for the suicide
belts and the gasket well they have
people in custody that has to be an
advantage for a law enforcement iams you
see everybody's dead this is an
advantage for the intelligence community
Fran Townsend thank you very much thank
you